welcome to the across the spoiliverse
podcast I'm your host Tony Stark oh I'm
I'm wearing glasses because obviously
I'm done in this weekend Greg I'm going
to be honest with you I've had
tonsillitis all weekend my throat's
killing I've been worn out and I was
that tired today that when uh Katie's my
wife's uh father-in-law came round I
just laid down on the dog's bed just to
to rest and I fell asleep on the dog's
bed so uh it's not been a good day but
we're here we're bringing you guys the
best episode ever as per usual and we've
got a lot to talk about how's it going
it's going good neither of us are sleep
deprived today we're gonna be great we
usually shoot these on Mondays we're
recording this on Sundays on a Sunday
today on Sundays this clearly shows
where my brain is at and yeah yeah
because we we heard wind of a Loki
trailer so I'm assuming it's still
coming out after right I mean after the
trailer right yeah so magic of editing
the Loki trailer we haven't seen it yet
but by the time this video drops we'll
have seen it so might change our
opinions on stuff but Greg what we're
going to talk about today and we're
going to do a quick rundown of the box
office because you're a self-proclaimed
box office expert every single week you
were like I'm here to deliver the good
news about the box office and okay I'm
gonna talk about
my God uh Marvel and the state of Marvel
and the secret Invasion finale and just
her overall feelings and who knows who
knows maybe they're dropping that Loki
trailer just to make us forget about the
Disney plus experience we all just had
and that is making headlines everywhere
it's crazy time because everyone's
turning everyone even the outlets that
are all about Marvel they're all turning
the shells you especially me
specifically Ryan Aries second who one
day will be here on this podcast which
I'm excited for sweet guy yeah so that
episode's got eight percent on Rotten
Tomatoes at the moment which I I think's
a bit harsh I think that should be
reserved for stuff like you know the
worst of the worst Catwoman I'm talking
that level uh but it just shows like how
that is brand damage to me that is just
the Brand's completely ruined at this
point where even you know the good stuff
doesn't get the highest score it's kind
of like what we saw with the DC EU you
know there were some really good movies
in there but they they the brand damage
was just so bad that critics would just
say I'll just give it a bad Mark anyway
I don't care anymore but yeah we'll talk
about that in just a bit Greg what is
the the box office rundown so I can look
and clever and not alone go ah bloody
I'll spit out Randomness while while you
uh get precise information even though
you text me stuff I'm just gonna read
what he what uh Paul texted me the
barberheimer box office
93 million dollars it made uh over the
weekend with only a 42
42.3 percent dip that's amazing I'm
learning this in real time guys that's
that's a really good hold
worldwide 750 million dude do you
remember when when uh Margot was saying
how
how she was pitching that Barbie could
make a billion dollars and she might
have overshot it a little bit this looks
like it actually has a shot at making a
billion dollars that's crazy that drop
as well yeah with that drop
um that's so impressive
I mean I might even do it this week you
know that's so good it's like 750
million worldwide that's insane
um Oppenheimer worldwide boxes box
office is 400 million after accumulating
46.2 million with a 44 drop damn man
barberheimer is holding this is so good
this is the seventh biggest second
weekend in history for these films only
surpassed by the likes of the force
awakens end game Infinity War black
panther Jurassic world and the Avengers
that's kind of nuts because there's
obviously a certain kind of category for
those IPS and to see what these movies
are doing especially for Oppenheimer
being an R-rated film it's nuts man but
then you know we got our Disney talk
haha ah Bob Iger take it take it Bob it
failed man yeah so Haunted Mansion I
mean we've been saying this for ages
haven't we I'm not saying like I'm a box
office expert or anything you are you
know occasionally get stuff right and uh
one of the flops that we said was a
guaranteed flop was the Haunted Mansion
film
um it's came in with a 33 million debut
at the worldwide box office that's
worldwide as well that's not just
domestic
um and yeah the film's got a budget of
150 million Disney just can't get a hit
right now I remember
yeah I remember watching podcasts
um a couple of years ago when they were
talking about the big earners for for
the air and I think it was around the
time the Last Jedi came out it was Toy
Story 4 basically and but they were
going over how all of Disney's movies
that yeah passed the billion Mark and
they would just dominated the box office
that yeah and at the moment they've had
like flop after flop after flop even the
stuff that does you know all right it
just tends to break even
um and it's it's crazy and this secret
Invasion stuff we getting a bit crazy so
do you want to jump into that next and
just kick off what were your thoughts on
the secret Invasion finale Greg oh man
uh it's weird because after four after
episode four I started like three
started showing glimmers of okay this is
a dip it's still fine but it's a dip and
then four was like oh uh I don't know
man this is really starting to go down
for me you were already on the train
kind of I don't really like this and
then five immediately was nope this is
this is not good this is just not good
and then by the time we got to the
finale
yes it is not a good finale it is really
bad it is a really bad finale I can't
say I was disappointed only because like
am I disappointed by the overall series
sure but unlike my experience with
something like Moon Knight for example
or I'll even say Hawkeye there's
something like Hawkeye where it's
penultimates of those shows weren't so
egregious then the finales were like oh
they really dropped they really fumbled
it in the finale though this was already
fumbling the ball so much and it already
dipped like significantly that it was it
was a weird experience because as the
show kept going the the quality of
Storytelling and overall filmmaking just
kept going downhill so by the time I got
to thumb like yeah it's really bad but
they primed me to be um they've primed
me throughout this this season to uh
have a bad finale and it was a it was
embarrassing there's a lot of silly
stuff and yeah I bitched about it for
like a solid 20 30 minutes something
like that in our video I just couldn't
stop because yeah I mean like it's easy
to really complain about it so I want to
get like some quick Pros out of the way
I kind of like the ending with Nick Fury
and his wife I thought there was that
was a little sweet even though it didn't
really like emotionally do much for me I
thought it was like oh this is this
looks fine I like the book end of Fury
arriving on Earth alone and then leaving
with someone I thought that was nice and
there were parts of the fight I got so
many issues with that fight though with
Gaia and grab I got so I got so many
issues with the plan it just in general
which there's so many problems with it
but the visuals have looked worse in a
Marvel Disney Plus show before so I'll
be like yeah it was
it wasn't as bad as it normally has
looked there were times where the
visuals were kind of all writing and
kind of look cool but the fight context
itself and then what they did with Kaia
was wow Overkill
what did you think buddy yeah so I'm
kind of used to it at this point
um obviously we've been covering MCU
shows for a while now and all and I knew
for a fact going in that they do this
like so I was writing my script on the
day
um and normally you know I I write it as
I watch it so if there's a big twist oh
crap I've got to go back and rewrite the
entire thing to recontextualize it to
talk about this twist so start off five
minutes and you know talking about Nick
Fury saying like well the conversation
he's just had with his wife
um on the phone it's a bit weird that
um it doesn't really say like I love you
anything doesn't feel like a final
farewell and then I just realized like
as he was coughing I was thinking well
he's dead if he goes into a reactor like
this
um so it can't be Nick Fury it can't be
Nick Fury it has to be Gaia who we
haven't seen she's not with them Vara so
I just I just thought oh I'm gonna
rewrite that sentence back there
um and then yeah when we got to that
point I was like yep clearly Gaia
um I personally think that Fury should
have based off against gravic and just
looking at the way the his whole
character Arc was handled
um he's faced no accountability at all
so he basically used Scrolls to be his
assassins and spies got children drafted
into his ranks which is what graphic was
he didn't get them at home
he also collected all of his mates DNA
to make a super weapon almost got his
wife murdered got Maria Hill killed
cocktails killed and in the end started
a cold war with the Scrolls and humans
didn't face any accountability for it
was just like right I'm off I'm going
back up to saber and I think that he
actually left the world in a worse place
than when he first came down to sort
everything out he was now prime minister
yeah Prime Ministers are getting gunned
down in the street uh there's like a war
there's a war going on where there's
like
um I don't know how to properly you know
talk about the the con let's say the
conspiracy theorists with guns they're
going around to shooting people you know
some suspect they're Scrolls summed up
that that [__] to me should have been
the season that should have happened
about episode three and then from there
you know Nick's trying to sort this
thing out or whatever that would have
been crazy and intense it would have had
a real pulse to it yeah and according to
what Daniel rpk said like take this as a
rumor but there's not any mention of the
Scrolls in Brave New World or anything
they so it's not like they're they're
building towards something which we
often feel with the Disney Plus shows as
well you know they they lead into
something big at the end and then yeah
by the next movie they kind of worry
that oh crap what if people haven't
watched this show which judging by the
viewing figures people haven't watched
this show so they don't really mention
it
um and I just feel in general like
there's too many characters in the MCU
at the moment who We're Not Gonna See
for at least a couple of years there's
lots of overpowered characters and also
there's so much going on that it's
actually difficult to have impactful
things because we know that these
creatives who work on these shows
they're not working together as one big
cohesive unit so for example the
directors come out and said you know he
he thinks the Roady switchover happened
during Civil War but he doesn't know for
definite because no one's actually told
him and if you look at the showrunners
behind all these things they belong
please come out and say something stupid
like Sam Raimi I love the guy but I'm
sure he even said he hadn't watched One
Division you know what I mean the
writers didn't watch One Division yeah
and I feel like at the moment there's
too many different projects that you
can't end on a massive oh [__] moment
you know what I mean you can't you could
with Loki because it was set outside of
time and space but all these ones that
are really connected to other things
um you can't have that old [__] moment
in the end because it's gonna [__] all
the other projects completely it's gonna
lead to a point where
which I feel now whether you see I'm
going into the finale looking at the
runtime being like it's a 30 minute
finale it's not nothing major is going
to happen and if it does it's going to
be downplayed quite a lot and never
really be brought into the movie so for
example Gaia bloody hell overpowered you
could one shot the entire Avengers
lineup she's got all their powers got
thanos's powers who completely wreck
them Captain Marvel's powers like she is
insane we we haven't heard of her being
in any of the films and it looks like
she's just gonna go work for Sonia and
probably being like some Mi 13 TV show
where
it's it's gonna I feel it's gonna damage
the brand because once you take the
stakes away it it and you sort of lose
the impact of these shows because we are
hitting that point where people just
aren't watching them anymore
um I think it's really Gonna Hurt the
brand I think they have destroyed the
brand of Marvel as a whole and I think
we're seeing that in the fact that all
of secret invasions episodes have been
reviewed as rotten people just aren't
you know vibing with it that much the
viewing figures are down a Samuel Samuel
L Jackson LED secret Invasion TV show
that's crazy to me phase four should
have been secret Invasion so you come
out of end game
it's a big big end of the phase you
start far from home
big twist at the end
um Nick Fury and Maria Hill have been
Scrolls the entire time
now that that was quite an interesting
thing and though they immediately cut to
like Nick Fury lounging about on saber I
think had they done things the other way
and just not had that scene you know
left a bit of intrigue like what the
hell's going on phase four you can have
every single film sort of setting things
up you know have Rory appearing in
movies and be acting a bit suspicious
you're like what's going on with Roadie
even Falcon in the Winter Soldier which
he appeared in there's nothing there to
give it away and I feel like they're
they retconned this Roadie twist because
there was no way that any of the
previous projects that wrote that they
were like yeah Roadies are scroll during
this no way this was a last minute thing
yeah and that they've tried to retcon
and retroactively push into these older
films and if you go back and watch them
don't hold up mate they don't they don't
I think I mean I did a video talking
about specifically why I I think that
twist is so stupid if if that is the
reveal that Roadie has been
I mean the thing that people don't even
factor in with the Roadie the scrotie in
in this in the secret Invasion show
itself as that even makes that portrayal
worse of what that character is depicted
like of this scroll having literally
no emotional attachment or Association
to humanity after freaking dealing with
the blip and and then helping to repair
50 of everything in the world like to
have none of that and to even have the
hive mind connection or whatever that's
called when they're neurally linked up I
really thought that secret Invasion
could do something very interesting and
this was something that didn't even dawn
on me till the finale when we got to the
to the Roadie moment where we could see
what the conflict must be like for a
scroll when they are taking on the
memories they're taking on their state
of mind and everything there has to be
some type of dichotomy for them and
especially for a show that was claiming
to be about dichotomy it really doesn't
do it with its characters so and even
like the scrotie never bothering like
when he's going around the hospital with
a gun scared of Nick Fury I'm watching
this going doesn't scrotie have the the
the war machine suit can can't he access
this suit at some point he's he's just
so reliant on his pistol and other
political games that it to me the
scrotie just becomes Dumber then on all
accounts if that's the case and yeah I
don't like the idea if he has been there
are like some Clues sure like people go
to the hospital again but it's also the
fact that he's limping and [__] and so I
understand that there can be some Clues
I don't
for I don't fully believe that to be the
case if it is I think it completely
undercuts so much of roady's Journey is
this is kind of going back to what you
were talking about at the very beginning
here which is about how these a lot of
times these filmmakers that come out and
are like oh we don't actually know this
we don't know that we didn't watch One
Division yada yada and I think the
problem is is that they do have so many
projects and Marvel they are huge on
secrecy obviously but they're too big on
secrecy within its own company within
its own you know cast and crew
specifically the crew like if you're
going to be doing all these stories that
are reactionary to Prior projects that
are coming out that are all Tethered to
each other you you need to have everyone
on the same white board connecting the
dots you know so that way they can all
properly tell the story they need to
tell because the secrecy is just way too
high to the point where they don't a lot
of times the consequences aren't even
felt anymore by the time you get to the
ending of things you know I was joking
about how as you were saying where
they'll set this thing up because
especially phase four is is a big
example of it and and now we're in Phase
five where they'll introduce something
they'll enter this big plot point that
should affect the world and then it just
doesn't carry over like how like with
the hand and internals it's the original
that's a one example of it and I'm even
under the impression
that even though this show sets up the
marvels of what Nick Fury is planning on
doing I really don't think it's going to
factor in that much by the time we
actually get to the Marvels I I just
don't have the faith anymore that
they're going to really when you're
looking at the trailer for the Marvels
they're dealing with a completely like a
much bigger thing on their hands right
now a much bigger Cosmic thing and a
completely separate plot that they don't
have time to do the resolution of what
Nick Fury is aiming to do when he sets
off at the end of secret Invasion
there's just no way they're gonna have
time to do that and if they do it's
probably going to be just another rushed
MCU movie at that point so I think they
need to get all their ducks and orders
so that way they can get [__] done
there's so much to complain about with
this with this this show man I mean I
wanted to ask you about your thoughts on
this because one thing that really
bothered me
um I mean it's there's so much to talk
about was
when you do the president ritzen moment
and he is saying you know I'm gonna
we're gonna hunt down all the strolls
we're gonna kill all them
it was so frustrating to me about that
was I feel like there was this massive
Gap where they didn't show us was there
a moment where Nick Fury and Olivia
Coleman had a discussion saying hey
president ritzen the reason you're alive
is because a scroll named Talos he's the
one who saved your ass now the whole
point of Talos dying was for this just
cause so that way there could be like
they they completely dropped the
greatness of it I can totally see a way
where yeah president would still land on
that
but it just seems like batalus's death
completely goes to waste in that moment
because this show doesn't acknowledge
there's no after effect of it Maria
Hill's death also feels wasted too they
she dies in the beginning you get the
funeral at the beginning of second of
the second episode and then it seems
like the show sets it up that this is
going to be some type of personal
conquest or some type of retributions
one of the many many factors for Nick
Fiori's portrayal here
and it's never really a thought other
than the few times where Nick Fury's
goes I didn't do that I didn't I didn't
kill her other than that her death is
also wasted so they have these deaths
that they treat as consequential and
important but they're never really
brought back up or are truly in service
for the story even for even for Gaia to
a certain extent you know that even that
feel felt weak when her point the point
of her she's the daughter of Talos and
for some reason just feels like Lost In
the Mix of this being a part of her
identity portrayal in the show so I mean
yeah I was curious what you thought
about that
totally agree
um the way I was thought that they could
handle it is written appears in Brave
New World and that's when they dropped
the bombshell like no Talos died to save
you remember that and that's when he
pulls back his forces but just judging
off the 110 president line I don't think
the guy's even gonna appear in the movie
I think we're gonna start off with
Harrison Ford already as the president
and that's going to be it
um
yeah really I really don't think they're
written I think rich and might get
mentioned but I mean Ritz and becoming
president was just like a throwaway line
on the news techer in wakanda Forever
there's a bit where they're watching
about raimonda's death and if you read
the news ticker along the bottom it
talks about President written I don't
think it's like they're gonna give it
much Focus because again people don't
watch the TV shows as much as they need
to
um and yeah I completely agree tell us
his death was just what was the point
um I was throwing a ryanairie at the end
of
um episode five and you know when Nick's
Rings up and he's like let's do this to
someone and he was thinking that that
was going to be Maria Hill and that
she'd been
you know hiding in the background the
entire time helping Nick to manipulate
things but completely pointless
obviously just talking to grab egg just
trying to Hype things up or talking to
Nick we'd never find that out
um and I think one of the the big missed
opportunities in the show is that we
never have like a crazy oh crap there a
scroll reveal you know what I mean it's
I I was comparing it in my review to
something like the thing which is you
know a similar sort of movie setup wise
where you've got
lots of different we've got different
characters and there's a shape shifter
among them that can steal someone's
memories and look exactly like that
person now you're watching that whole
movie paranoid as hell like just
wondering trying to pick out Clues who's
the thing no one knows and then they
somehow like on that first watch that
the characters that you least suspect as
well they're the thing
um and I I feel like they
there wasn't that big reveal moment
there wasn't a crazy turnout someone was
a scroll we knew from the off after the
Everett Ross thing that you know pretty
much everyone who was going to be a
scroll and that was due to the lack of
cast obviously if you have secret
invasion is basically like your Avengers
some of them are Scrolls some of them on
you're gonna have to really pay
attention to stuff when you've got one
Avenger in the entire cast it's
obviously the Skrill is and when it's
rolly like this is something people have
been saying for years like roady's gonna
be the skull and secret Invasion so that
just really stripped things away I think
the way the the show should have ended
was that Sonia should have revealed
herself to be a scroll and I think that
would have been like oh crap and that's
how she knew all the Intel she knew
about the squirrels in the first place
and so that's obviously like me putting
my own opinion on stuff that it's not
what we got and but I think just an
extra reveal even like President written
at the end reveals himself to be a
scroll or something I mean he's doing
this all for his own political games to
draw attention away from him just
something extra to really make you feel
like paranoid and like oh we didn't we
didn't know it the entire time and I
feel like I was always ahead of this
show even the twist with Gaia at the
reactor I was like yeah guy yeah don't
bother me writing the script yeah so I
mean once I once I head into a reactor
and start coughing and drop the pills
I'm like well there's loads of shots
from the trailer we haven't seen him
Nick looking great in his classic
uniform so it's obviously gonna be gonna
be like that Marvel completely they
completely undercut it right with
Marvel's yeah they completely this it
removes all Stakes when you're fully
aware well Nick Fury is going to be in
the Marvels they've been reminding us
about that so he's gonna be fine
yeah it's they did they did it with them
before end game released as well they
released the far from home trailer and
it was that obvious that people were
like
well maybe this is set in between
you know this is set before infinity War
because at the start of infinity War
they're coming back on a bus from a
school trip and people are doing like
mental gymnastics to just excuse stupid
marketing that spoils the movie
um and just looking at everything I feel
like the MCU has lost its clout now now
movies are getting delayed left right
and Center at the moment so this might
be out of date tomorrow and but at the
moment
the Marvels is actually knocking any
IMAX screens due to June booking them
out for five weeks now if you told me
that like even last year that
I would have thought you were crazy
because I thought Marvel is basically
what the entire film industry is built
around they the cinemas rely on these
big movies to come in they always make
money they always smash it at the box
office and the amount of films that have
been pushed out to to give Marvel room
to breathe and now they're not even
getting the iMac screens for June which
you know first film was pretty
successful it didn't completely do
Insane numbers but to be fair it was
released on HBO Max same day it still
did quite well
but I would have you know it kind of
feels like a almost an odd house sci-fi
movie
um obviously it's based on a famous
novel but I still would have thought
like you know billion dollar grossing
Captain Marvel sequel that would have
been what people were booking out and
then said they're like nice so it's my
June 2 and it just seems like Desi
haven't got the clout anymore because
they've had so many bombs back to back I
doubt haunted mansions can help them out
as well Indiana Jones has been an
incredible flop
Little Mermaid did all right Elementals
is actually you know starting to do all
right but it's been a long time coming
and you know whether it makes a massive
profit is something we're not going to
see for for a while
um and I just think like look at the
other day on my Twitter I put out a poll
saying looking at the lineup on the
upcoming slate do you think phase five
will be better than phase four now forty
percent said yes 34 said no 25 said
maybe
um and yeah I mean I've been looking at
the lineup and I'm not even sure how
confident I am that it's gonna be better
because you've got like fair enough Loki
season two is probably gonna be good
Daredevil but I don't know what the over
and under for Daredevil being good is
because every time I think it's gonna be
good they'll come out and say something
stupid like we're not having we're not
foggy Nelson's not gonna be in the show
or the stunt man will be out saying it's
crap
um Thunderbolts might do all right
Captain America bribe New World my two
alright
um fantastic for bloody hell the casting
with that at the moment jeez obviously
the strikes you know delaying that being
announced but it is I really don't know
I mean I'm a little I'm still I'm not
fully confident about Loki season two if
I mean Frank with you I I love Loki a
lot of people will say that's probably
the best one of the shows
um but the director whatever her name
was uh do you remember her name I forget
her name is she left the show uh
differences and then they brought in the
people who did Moon Knight to direct the
show now and to me when you see her of
how she talks about her experience with
Loki season one it just sort of reminds
me of when Scott Derricks and you know
did Doctor Strange and then he was
supposed to do multiversa Madness and
then because you know there was things
like no we got to implement this we got
to do this we gotta do this it started
it's it took over so much of the
creative behind it that they the
director jumped ship that's the same
impression I mean I like multi of you
and I both like Multiverse of Madness
maybe we can still acknowledge its
messiness
we like it as a Sam Raimie movie we like
we like some rainy movies and it's uh I
can totally see why your general MCU fan
is just like what the hell is this yeah
it's like turning it and I like the
directors of Moon Knight
um but there's just knowing that fact
did get me concerned about what they're
gonna do that it's probably going to be
a movie that's really this is our chance
to truly set up the Multiverse and that
was a huge show because that was a that
was a Disney Plus show as much as the
shows don't matter as much
um One Division and Loki seem to really
matter especially Loki Loki seemed like
a very important one you know even the
talk of Ant-Man after the post-credits
scene was the clip from Loki so you know
I think it's actually an important one
that people pay attention to but even
like
early on they were showing that stuff
didn't really matter because they had
Ralph boner as the big reveal there was
so much potential I had with that too
and I'm I know we've been moaning about
Ralph boner for years but there was so
much potential with that to launch the
X-Men from it or do something weird
because we all thought like oh it's
gonna open up the Multiverse at the end
of this movie and you know it's mmps is
going to be revealed to be From Another
Dimension or something
um and like Loki I think is good because
it's the only show that doesn't devolve
into a big CGI fight at the end where
it's just like people knocking each
other that you don't really feel any
impact for and I I think a show like
this should have had a smarter ending
where it needed to be actually graphic
versus Theory and fury outsmarting him
with his wits instead of just being like
Oh guy you know what I know I ruined the
guy's life or whatever I know he's
turning into a terrorists but you you
just go sort it out mate and uh if if he
some if he falls into the Trap and he
gives you super scroll Powers then you
sort it but uh if he somehow throws you
out of the machine or anything so I was
blood but uh it's over what I hate about
that scene so much hey I think gaia's
plan is stupid as hell I think it's a
really stupid plan I'm gonna hand over
the the harvest and I gotta I gotta
really hope that we're both gonna be in
this like accelerator machine that way
we both get the powers and then I'm
gonna go off the chances that we can use
these powers and I can use my powers and
beat him how do you even know you can
use them like how do you even know I
hate that Trope I generally in a fight
scene I I hate that Trope of there's no
figuring out no figuring out how to use
any of these
what is the classic scene in like
Superman movies or something when he
he's learning how to use it even go
crazy yeah the powers go crazy in
America like when he's running in the
first movie when he's all buffed up he's
like whoa I can run you know and that's
just running so the fact that she knows
how to be like sleep I know how to use
my mantis power uh I I thought it was so
so dumb I'm my bigger issue with that is
who's what's the character Arc here with
Gaia and fury because
you know
um
Fury when he's talking with uh gravic in
in the accelerator he he's lamenting so
much and he's even talking about you
know what my thought was when I started
getting dusted away he's explaining what
is you know I'm not gonna finally let go
of all this stuff well I'm like well
this is a Nick Fury's Arc this guy is
the one saying all this [__]
am I supposed to take it like Gaia is
speaking through the voice of Nick Fury
or she now understands his perspective
so that sort of character Arc how does
Gaia know all of this because they
clearly didn't talk about any of this
[__] and she's not mind connected to him
she's just putting on the skin so how
does she know all this unless there was
another off-screen conversation and like
you make sure to go through all this
when we're talking with Graphics or
something so I'm like whose character
Arc is happening in this moment right
now and uh yeah I think it's really weak
stuff I think the shows and everything
got so focused on the end points man and
they they handle their
I hate the Casual reveals of stuff with
Roadie gravic's death was just so it's
done I'm laying on the ground and then
even Nick Fury returning the form in in
his like that that imagery of him being
in his classic suit the eye patch no
beanie on
that the trailers made more of an impact
of that when they show the door open and
it's Nick if you're like oh Nick fear is
returning and it's supposed to be kind
of like a symbolic thing of how the show
is saying Nick Fury is not his former
self anymore and this is supposed to be
a symbolic of his ark but then in the
show he just like walks into the house
to talk to his wife it's just like a
casual thing but the trailers made more
of a moment out of it than the actual
show did so I think the I think they're
the yeah the rushingness of the you said
it earlier the second you saw the run
time you instantly knew this is going to
be another rushed mess
yeah so uh with the the guy thing I took
it as I knew that was a clue that it
wasn't actually Nick Fury because
I can't remember exactly what she said
but it was something like I felt
disappointed or something in how bad
this podcast is but I thought no in that
scene he's clearly reaching out to Carol
Danvers and saying [__] so I I
knew that that wasn't Nick Fury but that
conversation you're completely right
Nick Fury should have had that with
graphic at some point because does this
now actually mean that he couldn't find
them a home or are we meant to take that
as
nah this is this guy just winding him up
so that he'd go and sort the Harvest out
to inject her with powers and stuff
um so yeah it's just
again it just feels like another missed
opportunity which unfortunately I feel
is becoming commonplace with all of the
the shows at the moment you know one
division enjoyed it
um felt the ending was a bit
disappointing bark in the Winter Soldier
loved everything with us agent being a
kind of dark Captain America
um the flag smashes oh to be fair to
Falcon in the Winter Soldier
um they had a lot of issues like a hell
of a lot of issues because it was filmed
during covid and they had to reshoot
pretty much most of the Season
especially attending um because it was
they actually had elements of a pandemic
in the show originally um and if you
cast your mind back you can you might
you might remember the flag smashes
stole you know vials of something that
they were going to release into the
atmosphere and then that point just got
thrown away
um so to be fair you know that show was
as good as it could have been
because they had so much pressure on
them but think about everything you just
brought can I interrupt really quick
let's see like think about everything
you just brought up I'm so sorry to
bring her up
you're you're because you're bringing me
back to things I completely forgot about
uh when you retired Falcon and Winter
Soldier
you said us agent and
and I'm going oh yeah that's right he
was in that show and and he's okay you
brought up one division with the Ralph
boner thing and I think the Ralph boner
thing is is it's the poster boy for the
symbolic nature of of what Marvel has
become it really is that even with Loki
you know as impactful and crazy of an
ending as it was
where we thought this is going to be the
craziness that sets up the Multiverse
if you look at vast majority of the
projects that followed after it it
didn't seem like there was much effect
after Loki season two they eventually
brought it back with quantumania and
well Iggy has said some yeah what if
sure but if that doesn't even really
clarify that there's really something
going on you know and um and and then
with Thunderbolts they're taking I mean
U.S agent they're taking it takes so
long to get to Thunderbolts it takes so
long to bring all this stuff around so
they have all these things happening
that I'm completely forgetting about
Captain America we still hear way more
references constantly Marvel is
constantly reminding us about Steve
Rogers and no one ever brings up that we
have a new Captain America actually we
have Sam Wilson they want us to just
accept you know by the time we get to
Captain America the fourth one that we
have a new cap right and this but the
MCU keeps reminding us about Steve
Rogers instead and you never hear an
acknowledgment about a different Captain
America out there so they have all these
things that they keep setting up but
you're not seeing how any of this is
really truly having uh an impact or it
just takes too [__] long to get to
the thing they set up it takes so long
to get to that payoff that by the time
we get there oh yeah that's right that
that thing happened a lot of that's how
a lot of it's been for me is the oh yeah
I think delaying stuff
um and having long gaps can actually
help stuff sometimes so for example you
know Invincible season two I'm sure I
read that it's three years since the
first season yeah
um you know the boys has gaps in between
House of the Dragon has like two year
gaps in between its Seasons which I'll
talk about housing the dragon in just a
bit as well
um
and across the spider versus another
great example you know big gap between
the first film and the second one
but there's nothing kind of distracting
you during that now with the MCU shows
the characters they're not going to
appear for a while but there's so much
other stuff going on in it that you just
forget and don't really care anymore
um and I feel like you know you're gonna
have that moment where you're like oh
yeah crap I remember but like I'm gonna
tell you Greg well I think the worst
trivial in a TV show or if shared
universe is ever I think it's Hulk Sun
score who is just brought out at the
barbecue and like oh this is my son's
car by the way I'm not gonna remember I
remember them for this video but in like
five years time or whatever when he
finally comes back around I'm gonna be
like have I seen this guy before yeah oh
yeah he was in She-Hulk isn't she really
isn't she I don't remember what episode
was that and for the amount of time they
wasted in She-Hulk like
the so many episodes in there that I
don't remember at all they could have
had an episode just send it around Scott
and introducing him you know what I mean
and it's just like these last minute
things where I'd say uh we'll we'll
figure it out down the line just drop it
in because we're good we're planning on
doing some of this but we don't we're
not actually developing them now but
yeah just just drop it in
um and I just feel like
you're hitting a point of you know we
talk about superhero fatigue a lot and
as much as we're like we we don't think
it's real we think it's bad movie
fatigue that does hit a point where you
just get fatigued with superhero movies
in general and this year has shown it
because you know the flash didn't do
well Shazam didn't do well blue beetles
opening weekend meant to be like between
10 to 17 million there's clearly
something here going on where
even your big projects like your secret
Invasion we're gonna go CR didn't even
get a million viewers first week which
is
like mental what if you told me like 10
years ago secret Invasion would would be
made into a TV show where the scrolls
are trying to take over Earth and Nick
Fury's trying to hunt them down I went
oh yeah the MCU baby this is the best
franchise in the world and that just
just dropped it all but I don't
I don't think Captain Marvel set up the
Scrolls in a very exciting way either
you know and that was our introduction
to them so well they did but they they
did something different that the show
tried to undo so in that the scrolls are
sympathetic refugees whereas this is
it's been 30 years and the terrorists
now
it's like it just undermines the organ
that like I watched film speaks uh he
did a video essay on the other day and
he was talking about how it's actually
like problematic to have
especially in today's current climate to
have refugees like labeled as terrorists
and I was thinking yeah it's not not
really a good good message there Marvel
and uh yeah but for the fact that the
government's facing no accountability
their figurehead is just there he's just
kind of leaving the world up in a worse
place he's like oh whatever the brittles
sorted out come on Sonia
um and I'm I'm just reading through uh
article from the direct here that talks
about the seven biggest criticisms for
secret invasions bad review so uh yeah
we'll go through this and then any final
thoughts we'll let you guys get away so
the number one what could have been so
this Point's basically talking about you
know secret Invasion one one of the
biggest comic book events of all time in
the entire history of Marvel what were
you expecting coming in
what are you asking me yeah were you
expecting it to be a big thing or did
you have when I first heard about it I
thought it would be a big thing I've
read the comic I thought it was an
awesome it's an awesome comic so I
thought it would be more consequential
going I thought you were reading off the
direct things I don't have that in front
of me
um no I I expected it would be more
consequential and
the trait I I mean I don't know about
you but I thought the trailers were
great I thought the trailers were like
oh this looks taut and super tense and
and like a paranoia experience and to be
fair you know like we you and I really
like the first two episodes so we
thought that they were we thought it was
going to deliver we were we were
defending I remember on this very
podcast we were going yeah people I
can't get bad reviews but we really
loved it we thought it was great and now
we're now we're here a few weeks later
the checks stopped coming exactly yeah
check stop coming in strike happened so
now Studios don't pay us anything uh
yeah man that's it's just kind of
remember being exactly here with you
just defending the hell out of it and
now we're on this exact opposite train
it's so funny yeah second Point managing
new characters
so Gaia ended the series is arguably the
most important player on the board yeah
um but she's not really put forward as
an important character throughout most
of the season
um it's also yeah they're just talking
about basically all the sad characters
like Sonny falsworth Vera how you know
they're brought in
but they're not really given like
massive I suppose Gaia is because she's
the most important person in the Marvel
Universe now
um but she doesn't earn that [__] man
she doesn't earn it no no no it's hard
for anyone to earn that but especially
her getting like that overpowered is no
character there's no catharsis to it
there's no real payoff in it and it
honestly feels like it just kind of
comes out of nowhere you know yeah
completely agree um now why I wanted to
actually read this article out on the
podcast
um is because this next point which I
thought I never thought about before
uh but they're talking about death bait
so it's basically like your episode ends
on a big death or Cliffhanger to get you
to come back next week so Maria Hill
died episode one
crawl Fury wife reveal episode 2 episode
3 not too sure uh or gaia's death in
episode three sorry yeah Gaia apparently
died at the end of episode three but
obviously she came back next episode
which no one was surprised about because
again the marketing gave it away Talos
goes down in episode four
um and yeah it just they're saying
basically you know these deaths were
sold it's like oh crap oh my God and in
the next episode Fury's just like oh
whatever I don't really care like and he
doesn't he didn't seem impacted by
Maria's death at all Talos is death no
impact on him and he just kept moving
forward and was just like I gotta sort
this out I know who his scroll is I know
Brody's a scroll but I wait a couple of
episodes until I I confront them
yeah so next Point unless you want to
talk about that one for a bit
no I feel like we kind of talked about
it a little bit earlier too with the
death baiting man yeah it's a real it's
a real Pro yeah we talked about there's
there's no true residual consequences to
any of this stuff or is it something
that seems to factor into anyone's
character arcs really
yeah so the next point they're saying
the MCU super scroll
um saying you know originally super
Scrolls just had four powers which kind
of kept them limited
um whereas yeah they kind of jumped the
shark and gain the ability of virtually
every hero and villain in the history of
the MCU they applied zero subtlety to it
as they showed the range from Drax to
mantis to Thanos to Turning Gaia into a
remade Captain Marvel the worst oh the
worst offense of this other powered
character is that it left Gaia on the
board a character that has already had a
lesson Stellar introduction in the MCU
is now the most powerful player yeah and
they're saying basically the Superman
problem has made its way to the MCU
which Superman problem in case you don't
know guys too overpowered like what can
challenge him
um I feel like they're gonna do a
cop-out and basically be like
oh the powers only lasted for 48 hours
they wore off after a while
and it's just gonna be be a complete Cop
Out did they explain why graphic could
not heal
yeah I don't know because he got stabbed
in the exact same spot earlier in the
fight you get to glance through it with
that Frost giant arm or whatever and
then he gets shot through it yeah you'd
think that with having all the power
like so many Powers with extremists also
included in that mix that he would be
able to heal from that
yeah you know say we want about She-Hulk
man but they really they really uh
nailed down at the average did Disney
plus finale though they they ripped on
what happens usually they secret
Invasion immediately did it that's
actually 0.5
um which is She-Hulk warned about Marvel
Studios oh [__] finale yeah
um and it's basically talking about how
She-Hulk blatantly called attention to
them just you know resorting to these
CGI driven fights instead of focusing on
the story being told
um for they say for secret Invasion to
be this grounded Espionage story
everyone was waiting for you know a
cerebral ending um and what we get is
one of the most over-the-top CGI fights
that's just every Power of every hero
and villain just
action figures just smacking together
um yeah and the the sixth point is the
lack of a conclusion which again we've
talked about before you know
what theories left the planet like
there's like a cold war going on
um genocide of Scrolls and humans alike
guys off with Sonia falsworth to come
back at this initiative
um and yeah it's just kind of all over
the place with the most powerful
characters still left on the board uh
who could probably take over the planet
single-handedly I mean the Avengers
could come together but there's not many
people and the uh the final point is the
James Road situation
which yeah talked about that it's just I
I feel like they can't do it at Civil
War they just can't have that be the
turning point because it just robs the
character of so much development
um the most I mean the most impactful
moments that Roadies had in the MCU are
at least some of them
if it is Civil War it's saying he was a
scroll during that you know he's not
there for the death and funeral of Tony
Stark
um didn't make the the baby Thanos joke
they're saying
didn't witness the creation of Tony Tony
stunk
yeah it's just uh it's just stupid you
know what I I think that sure there is
an argument the reason why okay I'll
tell you why I don't why I don't love
this argument
because I've heard it they say I I
thought it too at first of okay well
there could be something really
compelling for Roadie to make it a truth
a true compelling character is never to
me at least been the most compelling
character right
and I think armor Wars was the idea
though here we could really start doing
it like Don Cheadle has always been very
charismatic and he's great support but I
wouldn't never I have never really been
like that's a compelling character he's
one of my favorites and it seems like
arm rewards could be the thing to set
him up for that and let's say let's say
it was Civil War and when it all started
and this is where it allows him to come
to all these realizations and and the
place that I belong and he wasn't around
for Tony's death and arguably he's the
one who might need to take up sort of
the Iron Man imagery now because he's
War Machine and then else but
as much as I think there's room for
potential for for something to make
really rich out of that character
I highly doubt my belief in the what
what they allow for their writers
because of how the studio rushes
everything now and doesn't really inform
their writers and the fact that they
want to make armor Wars they're making
armor was a movie now instead of a show
I don't feel like the movie would give
the proper treatment they would need for
Roadie to deal with the resolve on all
these things that he missed out on and
the experiences of grief like he's
there's so much the guy would have to
process and deal with that the movie
would probably just brush past a lot of
it or rush through a lot of it without
giving real service to it and the reason
I say that is because of how the MCU has
been lately that I highly doubt they
would be able to do it justice
yeah so I really hope that they
something feels like they were testing
the waters to see what their response is
I don't know if you get that impression
something like we're gonna intentionally
say we do We're Not Gonna intentionally
you know tell you guys exactly when this
took place where we're going to want to
see the response even though we have
ways some clues that it could be after
the events right after the events of
Civil War due to the fact that he can't
walk and all that jazz so it could be
that but you know I there's also the
argument that it could have just been
right after end game uh so yeah I think
I think it could have been after that I
think that makes the most sense
I I think that does because gravic
hadn't turned against Fury at that point
so there'd be no reason for him to be
abducting people and swapping them out
with Scrolls also looking at the
Timeline Greg
Civil War set in 2016.
secret Invasion set in 2025 that means
that a scroll was pretending to be
Roadie for nine years which I couldn't
be honest with it mate I couldn't be
also there nine years of doing that crap
um and I think one of the reasons that
the scroll didn't use any of Brody's
armor and why he he didn't use it in
Falcon in the Winter Soldier is because
that armor has AI in it that would
probably be coded directly to rhodey's
DNA and I think they might explain it
with that so if he try and gets in
because after um
Iron Man 3 obviously everyone's just
getting suits and getting the Iron
Patriot suit so I think they would have
upgraded it at that point because Tony
Stark's known for his upgrades
um and I think they would have made it
so that you know if you don't actually
have Rowdy's DNA you can't pilot it so
that's why I don't think it was in those
shows the only way I would say this like
scrotie would have been more of if the
Civil War thing would be effective if if
they revealed scrotie was the big bad of
it you know if he was The Mastermind it
makes no sense to me that this scrotie
would be gravic's [__] after every
single thing that he's been through
essentially dealing with like Thanos in
the battle for Earth you know there's
just no way I could see this guy going
yeah I'm just gonna answer the Gravity
from here on how it just makes no sense
to me yeah there comes a point where you
drop the cover as well I feel in that
final battle you know when Roadies
paralyzed the the iron when Thanos
basically attacks Avengers HQ you get a
cut to Rowdy who has red blood at that
point I must point out and but lying in
the the mark one suit that's destroyed
goes canopy canopy canopy rolls out
crawls across the floor to get into the
you know completely messed up trying to
free rocket from another Rubble I feel
at that point you know you stop
pretending to be paralyzed and just uh
get yourself out of there and yeah for
them to just keep up the ACT I mean they
couldn't even keep the act up during
like
some scenes with Nick at the hospital or
when they were having that drink you
know what I mean yeah um so yeah to keep
the act up throughout all that and I
think they're gonna see the backlash
from fans as well and just be like nope
uh it was Falcon on the Winter Soldier
guys you guessed it so yeah just just
stupid um
another thing you know we keep bringing
up Disney budgets and box offices I
think it's important to talk about
how much was spent on secret Invasion so
the budget is 225 million for six 40
minute episodes I'm gonna give you a
comparison talked about this on Twitter
at the weekend House of the Dragon 10
hour long episodes 200 million wow which
you compare like
you know you can't you can't show up the
house of the Dragon just wearing your
normal clothes you know what I mean
looking like Tony Stark you have to get
a proper outfit in costume and every
single actor's gonna have that secret
invasion you know I feel like you can
kind of do that it was always a shot in
location in places like art galleries
restaurants a lot of the time
um you know newsrooms not places that
are massive sets that you have to build
which you know House of the Dragon had
hell of a lot of sets going on
obviously the actors
um so I actually got information on how
much Samuel Jackson was paid he was paid
uh 20 million who's paid 20 million um
and then the other actors have paid like
I think 1.6 was the next highest
um amount and then it was from there
like dropping in lower increments
and yeah just to think like even if you
take away Samuel L Jackson's salary
they're both still 200 million shows and
looking at the run time you know 30
minute finale
House of dragons like all an hour-long
episode with Crazy CGI Dragon fights and
stuff that episode three when there's
the big fight at the end and then
there's loads of dragons and things I
just don't get where the money gone I
don't wear it don't get where the money
gone
um and from what people have been saying
as a reply to that
they've been saying that they basically
shot the show several times and changed
a lot of things
um and they they were also common saying
like Victoria alonso's just went crazy
with constantly changing the CGI so they
have to remake bits over and over and
over again obviously she's been let go
whether it's true or not we don't know
but
yeah like how do you even justify a
budget for this of that when you compare
it to prestige HBO television that you
know it it doesn't have a massive cast
in it but it's still got some big names
that are part of it
I just don't get it I don't get where
the money went
that's been the conversation of Marvel
man is what's happening with you
laundry because
it doesn't show on screen we all know
the stories about the VFX artist being
you know whipped around and not giving
enough time they're constantly changing
stuff so wherever that money is going a
lot of it doesn't truly get a shine on
screen because of the constant reworking
that they're doing
that things just don't get a shine man I
mean sheer Hulk was also super expensive
and the CGI on that was a massive
criticism for it quantumania got a lot
of criticism for it you know and they're
always they're always changing stuff
like okay so like the good superhero
ones like Guardians three we often
forget because I kind of just feel like
its own camp like that's a James good
movie even though it is a MCU you know
Js games Guardians 3 is the is the the
one thing in Marvel this year that a lot
of people seem to be on board for
and Spider-Man across the spider verse
but
yeah man it's bumming me out it's
bumming me up
um I'm hope more than I hope let's hope
maybe tomorrow
maybe like the thing is we're doing this
all this talk talking about Marvel right
and
the thing I I'm wondering is we were
shooting this before the Loki season 2
trailer comes out and I I know that
fans can be very reactive when it comes
to anticipation so yeah sure if the
trailer is awesome as hell
you know people there could be a huge
pendulum swinging where people are uh
Marvel's back look they're gonna be
saved Loki season two you know and
I think I think there's nothing that can
get me through right now everything is
I'm going to proceed with caution there
used to be a time where you're like yeah
Marvel's coming out with something it's
exciting and now it's Marvel's coming
out I'm I've made it this far we might
as well just keep do I I do Wonder
I I actually started wondering would I
be as on top of watching this stuff now
if I didn't cover it you know
um would I be as adamant if I'm making
sure to watch this stuff now or would I
be like I'll just wait for it all there
yeah I feel like I'm at a checkup I know
for a fact if I wasn't doing this as a
job I would have checked out but you
know I am excited for Loki obviously we
got that leak trailer from d23 I think
it was watch that I think that's a great
trailer you know I'm guessing it's going
to be sort of along the same lines might
not be the exact same trailer but
if it's you know if it's I'm gonna be
excited for it but um
I kind of do feel like I'm hitting a
point where even if it is really really
good I'm still gonna be like
you know fool me once shame on me fool
me twice shame on you it's kind of I got
it I just got a
thing the wrong way around
so this is popped up on my YouTube page
that says Marvel Shields finally come
out and criticize secret invasions trash
finale
I'm on the thumbnail for it excellent
and I'm like hey yo man I've been pretty
critical of Marvel all their stuff
lately it's just kind of funny that yeah
okay I guess I feel you get a lot of um
negative comments anyway I mean I got a
treat last week saying like I'm uh I'm
being way too negative
like far far too negative recently and I
should just be happy with what we're
getting and stuff and I'm like uh I
don't I feel like I'm critical but I
still try and get positives but
you know when you hit a point where it's
just kind of all the time it's getting a
bit
kinda
it's okay I remember being one of the
first ones to [__] about quantumania
publicly and I got so much crap because
yeah you did yeah because that was at a
time when people were like it's the best
movie ever we've uh We've made the com
like some people were saying it was like
one of the best sci-fi films ever made
and stuff and I was like no it's not
good guys and then and then weeks later
it all started coming out and uh yeah
um and then now something like that
something like this just makes me laugh
now no I gotta try I got I got a log
book here of one I've been critical yeah
for me it was still living Thunder but
to be honest with you Greg even now I'll
get tweets saying oh this is the yeah
but you said Black Widow was amazing and
I'm like I 100 didn't and I I have to
screenshot my review where I say I
thought it was really bad and send it to
them and then they just don't reply and
I'm like
I'm like mate I didn't say I gave it a
six out of ten you know what I mean I'm
not I wasn't singing it to Praises uh
yeah and it's it's they just get
exhausting the whole shill conversation
because it's like no matter how many
times you give like you'll say
something's bad you say something's good
you're a shell you say something's bad
you're a hater and there's absolutely no
in between because people are absolutely
moronic and we'll just jump to these
labels because they can't understand
nuances I honestly think they're just
buzzwords that people use because if
they were like people who thought secret
invasion was okay now say it's bad it
wouldn't get the clicks so it's like the
Marvel Shields getting there getting
crazy stuff they're finally turning
against it so it made that was like door
live and thunder I think my thumbnails
are are the most misleading parts of
that's the problem with my face and
thumbnails because I'm off I'm always
like what's like the most engaging
expression reaction if I you know if
there's if it's the reaction kind of
video and uh I think a lot of times that
can be misleading so I'm trying to just
yeah there's no way this person's
watched your like hour-long reactions
they're just seeing that you like Marvel
sometimes in that you've said secret
invasions but like it's a bloody shell
but he's turned against it he's turned
against it finally he's finally honest
yeah because like what can I say because
if I keep if I'd say something's bad I'm
now turning against the franchise if I
say something's good I'm chilling it's
like
guys are morons like I don't need a show
for like most companies hate me
genuinely because I spoiler films you
know Disney's not Disney's not ringing
me up going like can you drop a plot
leaks video on the Marvels and at the
end say that you're not you don't really
think it's gonna be that good like oh
yeah of course mate I'll spoil the
entire thing you know what I mean
yeah I gotta go to it okay
again well I know for a fact you're
gonna watch that video in full first and
be like oh well this is an hour and a
half I don't have time to waste
yeah so I'll watch it for you in a
comment on it saying great video you
really gotten his ass there even live
time stamps too this for the real reject
spot the best part was right here yeah
oh they got uh they got Cosmic Wonder on
it as well oh you found it no yeah I
just did I type Marvel shields in I
recently uploaded yeah finally got it
finally got it
yeah so yeah guys thanks for sitting
with us for another enthusiastic video
where we do get really negative on these
things which are we holding no we don't
want to be I just realized that we're in
the holding hands pose
we might be now
um sometimes they flip around randomly
but yeah guys uh thanks for watching our
marathon of holding hands if you want to
support the channel you know subscribe
to the podcast uh we drop it all the
time every week we're trying to do it
weekly we have done it weekly so far
it's also on Spotify Amazon podcasts
any other podcasts that you listen to
Apple podcast yet because we gotta pay
for that there's sums of the [__] so
yeah if you wanna those links are in the
description you can listen to us on the
go
um if you want to support the channel
and buy our merch then we can do that
and yeah we'll uh thanks a lot again for
sticking through this obviously we'd
also love to hear your comments on
secret invasion you know tell us that we
should be thankful for getting anything
and not have to go back and get proper
jobs uh for the shells call us uh haters
whatever you want mate but uh thanks for
engaging with us love you support's
really blowed us away yeah yeah honestly
you guys you make it you make it amazing
thanks a lot you take care peace